Buried here, deep in a Japanese mountain pass,
is one of the world's rarest technologies. A
43-kilometer-long magnetic levitation train track.
Which will eventually become part of the
world's first inter-city Maglev train,
connecting Tokyo and Osaka.
With the power of superconducting magnets,
these trains hover a mere 10 centimeters
above their track, while pummeling along at a
mind-boggling speed of 500 kilometers per hour.
With no physical contact required with
the track, they can operate in any weather
conditions and have lower maintenance costs
due to reduced friction and fewer moving parts.
Despite the advantages of Maglev trains
over traditional high-speed trains,
The only commercial high-speed Maglev
line currently in operation is just
30 kilometers long. Connecting
Shanghai Airport to it’s city.
A journey the train makes in only 8 minutes,
but a track this short largely defeats the
advantage of high speed maglev, by the time
the train gets up to speed, it needs to slow
down again. A 30 kilometer journey in 8
minutes actually equates to an average
speed of 225 kilometers per hour, slower than
the top speed of conventional high speed rail.
The planned future network of high-speed
maglev tracks, just 400 kilometers long,
and it pales in comparison to the extensive
network of 60,000km of regular high-speed
train tracks already in place around the world,
with an additional 50,000km under construction.
Why is this gap so large? Let's
delve deeper into how Maglev
trains work and explore the reasons
behind their restricted deployment.
We have two primary methods of levitating
a train. We can pull the train up using
attractive forces or push the train
upward using repulsive forces.
The pulling approach involves a combination
of a magnetic iron rail and an electromagnet
that uses attractive forces to raise
the body of the train. This is an
active system where the gap between
the rail and the magnet is crucial
as the strength of the attractive force
decreases with the square of the distance.
Meaning, the train needs active
controls and feedback loops ensure
that these gaps stay between 8 and
12 mm. If the train begins to drop,
the magnetic force holding it up will quickly
weaken, causing it to fall even further. It’s
an unstable configuration. These types of
trains are referred to as Electromagnetic
Suspension trains. This is the system the 30
kilometer line in Shanghai uses. [1][REF_00]
Japan opted to use a different
system, with a more significant
gap of 10 centimeters between the track and train.
8 times greater than the gap for electromagnetic
suspension, while also providing a passively
stable method of levitation. A vital property
to have in the earthquake prone region.[2]
In this approach, magnets onboard the train
interact with passive coils on the track. As
the train moves over these coils, they
experience a changing magnetic field,
which generates the opposing
field that lifts the train upward.
If the train is stationary on top of
the coils, there is no change in the
magnetic field. So this dynamic system only
works when the train is already going fast.
The trains have wheels that drop
down when the train is slowing down,
but flip into the carriage
when they reach 100 km/h. [1]
In order to achieve a stable position on
the track, the north and south poles are
arranged vertically on the sides of the track.
The magnets are formed from coils of wire,
arranged in a figure 8 pattern. A
south pole points upwards on one side,
while the north pole points up on the other.
If the train were to drop slightly or
move sideways, the magnets on the train
induce currents on the opposite coils,
generating a stronger magnetic field,
which pushes the train back to the
midpoint of the figure 8 shapes. [3]
This dynamic system is forgiving, with
the 10 centimeter gaps between the track
and the train naturally maintained with
no need for complex control inputs.[1]
However, the Japanese Maglev train, called L0,
will be the first of its kind. These trains,
known as SCmaglevs, need superconducting
coils to generate the extremely powerful
permanent magnetic field on the train.
These are the coils that induce the
changing magnetic field and allow the train
to levitate in a stable configuration.
These coils, located on each side of the
carriage, must be maintained below their
critical temperature to ensure their current flows
without resistance. The niobium-titanium coils are
cooled using liquid helium and placed inside
a container that is cooled by liquid nitrogen.
The coils are cooled using a Pulse Tube
Refrigerator [4]. Which uses
sound waves to cool the helium.
The same type of refrigeration cycle that the
James Webb telescope is using to keep its infrared
sensors cold enough to detect even the faintest
infrared heat radiation from the distant past.
A sound wave is just a pressure wave and
pressure and temperature are directly
proportional. Higher pressure
will cause higher temperature.
We can take advantage of this by creating a
standing wave, where the peaks and troughs
of the wave are stationary. We can do this in a
closed tube where the resonant frequency of the
tube is determined by the tube's length. Here
the sound wave will bounce off the closed end
and create a region of compression and high
pressure, and therefore high temperature.
We can now place a stack that spans this
hot region at the end of the tube to the
cold region at the centre. Now if we place
a heat exchangeron either end of the stack,
we can now transfer the heat to a
radiator and the cold side will conduct
heat away from the superconducting
coils. Keeping them cold. [REF] [5]
There are eight of these coils
per car, with four on each side.
However, having a magnetic field strength
of this magnitude right next to passengers,
and traveling by at half the speed of sound,
could cause some serious problems. Ferrous
objects aren’t allowed anywhere near MRI
machines. The engineers needed to find a way
to ensure the magnetic field did not extend into
the passenger cabins, or far away from the train.
We can’t block magnetic fields,
but we can redirect them,
in the same way we can conduct electricity
to where we want it to go using copper wires.
Where we measure the ease of passage
for an electric current with resistance,
we measure the ease of passage for a
magnetic field with reluctance. Where
copper has a low resistance,
Iron has a low reluctance.
We can use electric steel shielding to divert the
magnetic field away from the cabin and stations.
Electric steel contains 3% silicon and is
post-processed to produce large crystal
grains aligned in a specific direction, which is
controlled by a cold rolling process. The grain
oriented electrical steel can carry about
30% more magnetic flux in this direction,
allowing engineers to direct the magnetic
flux in the desired direction. [6]
However, this shield is heavy, so we want
to use as little of it as possible. Luckily,
we can also tailor the magnetic field shape
through careful design of the magnets themselves.
If we placed two parallel magnets like
this, north poles aligned horizontally,
the magnetic flux lines would run parallel
to the magnets and be densers between the
magnets. However, if we flip one of them,
the magnetic flux lines connect up and
create a kind of bubble in the between them. The
magnetic field will be weaker in this location.
This is how we arrange the coils on either
side of the cabin. There are 4 sets of coils
on each side. So we also need to flip the
magnets so the north and south poles face
each other. This creates a low magnetic
field bubble through the corridors. [7]
With the use of shielding, the field
strength is reduced to only 0.5mT,
almost equivalent to Earth's
the magnetic field. [7]
Of course, near the magnets the field's
strength is unavoidably high, and this
prevents us from using certain materials
in these areas. The tracks for example
need to be constructed from low-magnetic
steel, or fibre reinforced composites. [8]
But how does a levitating train propel
itself if it’s not touching the ground?
For conventional rail we just apply a torque to
the wheels that will push off against the ground.
Wheels are actually a bit of a middleman in the
development of torque. Many trains use
electric motors to turn their wheels.
The electric motors use electromagnetic force
to turn a shaft. What if we could
take the same motor and unwrap it.
This is called a linear motor.
Where alternating coils attract
and repel the train with precise timing. [2]
To brake the trains can use this system in
reverse, this is regenerative braking. Since
electrodynamic systems don’t work at low speed,
they also have brakes for their wheels. The
trains also feature an air brake that can slow
the train down very effectively at top speeds.
There is one other challenge when
dealing with contactless trains,
how do they get electricity? For lower-speed
Maglev systems they use a low friction third rail,
common in metro systems, to bring
electricity to the trains. [REF][2]
But as speeds get higher this isn't
practical [REF][REF_00] as it defeats
the purpose of reducing friction from
the rails. Some early versions of the
Japanese style electrodynamic system
actually had a gas turbine onboard to
provide power. But it now uses a linear
induction coil to collect power from the
changing magnetic field from the guiding
coils.[REF][REF] [9]. This does create a
magnetic drag force, but it’s more effective
than carrying a large generator on board.
The Japanese Line is set to be the first
long-distance high-speed Maglev train. Its
first phase, covering 285 km, will connect
Tokyo to Nagoya and is scheduled to open
by 2027. The second phase, which will
complete the remaining 438 km to Osaka,
is expected to be completed a decade later.
So why is Japan pursuing this futuristic
technology? Japan has long been at the forefront
of train technology. After opening their Tokyo to
Osaka Shinkansen line in 1964, the world's first
high speed train, they immediately began exploring
ways to reduce the 4 journey to under 1 hour.
Starting in the 1970s, Japan Airways and the
Japanese Central Rail Station constructed a
7km testing track here in.Miyazaki They began with
prototypes of trains that could reach speeds of 60
km/h in 1972, and by 1995, they had developed
trains capable of reaching up to 411 km/h.
As the Miyazaki test track became too short,
the Yamanashi test track began construction
in 1990. This 20km test track was conveniently
located between the cities of Tokyo and Nagoya,
along the route of the upcoming new Maglev line.
Here, they transformed the design from a prototype
to a fully functional train capable of carrying
700 passengers in 12 cars at speeds of 500 km/h.
But, high-speed Maglev trains are more
than just a science experiment. They are
an efficient and super fast way to move
people. But, building these trains is
more than just an engineering challenge,
they are also an economic challenge where
they have to compete against cars,
planes, and other types of trains.
Whenever Maglevs are brought up in the US, the
idea of traveling between New York and LA in
7 hours is often used as a statement of its
potential. It’s the very first line on the US
Department of Energy's own website. But a track
of this length makes little economic sense. [10]
If we plot the travel time for trains,
planes, and cars between say San Francisco
and LA. Two large population centers
within a reasonable driving distance,
this is what it looks like. Trains
are outright the best option.
Even though planes are faster, airports
are usually located far outside the city,
and security wait times increase the length
of the journey. A high speed train will save
passengers time, and in turn make an economy
more productive. A reduction of travel time
of 2 hours for 900 passengers equates
to 1800 hours. Equivalent to 75 days.
Faster trains simply extend the range at
which trains are competitive to airlines.
Large cities between 200 and 800 kilometers apart
are perfect contenders for high speed
rail. DC to New York in just 60 minutes.
This map shows the potential economically viable
high speed rail connections in the US. [11]
Unfortunately, as it stands, the US is
not investing much in high speed rail,
and Maglev systems are even harder to build.
They require completely new tracks that require
electromagnetic coils along the entire length
and specialized materials that are not affected
by the incredibly strong magnetic fields passing
by them at 500 kilometers per hour. The Japanese
line that connects Tokyo to Nagoya recently
had a price increase to 13.7 billion dollars.
Maglevs are between 10 and 50 times more expensive
than high speed rail. The incredibly successful
French high speed rail, the TGV built in
the 80s and 90s cost 2 million dollars per
kilometer [12]. The first stage of the Japanese
line is set to cost 77 million dollars per km [1]
Even when compared to the same route
from Tokyo to Osaka via High-speed rail,
the maglev system will cost 11.3 times
more per kilometer. That is a large
price to pay to reduce the travel time by 1 hour.
The Tokyo-Nagoya line is taking a more
direct route through mountainous terrain,
a staggering 86% of the track
would be underground. [13]
Tunneling over 200 km significantly increases
costs. Interestingly, this also leads to
increased operational expenses. When the train
travels in the open air at speeds of 500 km/h,
the unobstructed air simply moves aside. However,
when traveling through a tunnel, the air has no
escape route, this creates additional drag which
in turn increases the force required to propel
the train forward.
[14]
The energy usage of the new line will
30% higher compared to the existing
Tokyo-Osaka line . [14] But that’s
still vastly better than flying .[15]
For now, I don't see Maglev technology being
used beyond some special projects like this.
The radical increase in costs simply do not
justify the increases in top speed over high
speed rail. And it’s beyond imagination for
the US, we are struggling to get regular
rail service even in places uniquely
suited to it like the Texas triangle.
4 high population cities located in a triangle,
with only the hellscape of
interstate highways connecting them.
With the recent speculation about
the potential of room temperature
superconductors, a technology that would
make maglev trains vastly easier to build,
interest online in superconductor
technologies is higher than ever.
But a lot of it is unintuitive, and
actually understanding how magnetic
fields work is a fantastic tool in an
engineer's arsenal. So many of our most
important technologies depend on this physical
phenomenon. But, you don't have to pay for a
whole university level course to understand
the fundamentals. There's a free way you can
learn about magnetism and electricity,
with this fantastic course on Brilliant.
You can find this and tons of other courses on
Brilliant, including one of their new courses
“Predicting with Probability” Understanding
probability and applying it to everyday
situations is a great career tool, but
also just an everyday common sense tool
to help you navigate daily decisions.
I highly recommend taking this course.
Brilliant makes learning easy with fun,
interactive courses that really succeed
in getting you that dopamine rush
as they test your knowledge along
the way. They have a fantastic mobile
app so you can learn on the go too. .
Brilliant has thousands of other lessons too.
AI, data science, neural networks and even our
very own partnered Real Engineering course.
You can get access to that course right now,
and all of Brilliant's other curated interactive
courses, by going to brilliant.org/RealEngineering
or by clicking the link in the description.
You can get started for free for 30 days,
and the first 500 people to do so will get 20%
off Brilliant's annual premium subscription